[Music]
Quincy Jones everyone in the music
industry looks out to Quincy Jones it's
that simple he's just the best that
there ever was
in his field everybody says the same
thing that there is a light about him I
think Quincy Jones knows more
significant people who have changed the
world than anybody I've ever met what's
your legacy I don't have a clue I'm just
going to keep on doing my thing and hope
that it will mean something to somebody
a cross is more than seven decade career
Quincy Jones has become known as the
hitmaker composing more than 2 900 songs
and 300 albums that span genres and
generations Fly Me to the Moon
Quincy and Michael Jackson collaborated
on three of MJ's hit records including
the best-selling album of all time
Thriller we made it really Thriller in
eight weeks
the last day of Thriller could have been
a disaster we had put too much it was
vinyl in too much time on it 27 minutes
so I'm supposed to be 19 or it's thin
and tinny and we played it back and it
was horrible Michael was crying we
remixed one tune a day we were forced
into getting it right
at the time anybody that would say we're
going to make a record that's going to
sell 50 million records is lying because
it's not possible
Q as many column worked with many of the
greats including Dizzy Gillespie Louis
Armstrong and his Pals Count Basie and
Ray Charles but it was Frank Sinatra who
gave Quincy his big break with a single
call in 1963. he said I just heard the
record you did with basically I'd like
you to do my next record I'm doing it
with basic can you make it
are you serious I said you bet I can do
it man was it five minutes I'll be there
I was in New York Mr Quincy Jones right
now
kill and Quincy Jones
somehow our souls clicked if you look
closely Quincy still wears his gold ring
bearing Frank's family crest they left
me this ring when he died
and so I'll never take it off
throughout his career Hollywood came to
rely on Q as a go-to composer scoring
more than 50
TV shows
[Music]
and as a producer he discovered Mega
Talent like he stole my heart when he no
he stole mine stole my heart uh when we
did The Color Purple
oh my life are here to fight I turn on
to set 9 15 or something
I see that face
and you said that's so fair I don't care
what she can do this is this is this is
so good
in 1985 Oprah was a local talk show host
when Quincy picked her for the role of
Sophia in The Color Purple she earned an
Oscar nomination for her performance the
movie earned 11. what I hope and in the
bottom of my heart this will inspire
hundreds of young black filmmakers to
get into this field Quincy has an
on-screen star in the family too are you
excited definitely I'm fired up yeah I'm
fired up he's um very supportive of
anything I decide to do
his daughter Rashida is one of his seven
children from five different
relationships spanning nearly 40 years
in age at every chance he beams about
his blended family I am the luckiest man
on the planet I got the six daughters
and one son I am so proud of him
I always told him I want to be their
friend the parent first but I want to be
their friend because that's for life I
want to thank all my kids because they
taught me how to be a good daddy
they did
[Applause]
I really love my kids I really do I mean
not more than ever
[Music]